y no es salud si no hay economía con
Daniela Blandón Daniela vamos a dar un
repaso por el legado económico de
corbachov en la unión soviética bueno
es recordado por muchos como el
sepulturero de la unión soviética
comunista como lo hemos venido diciendo
muy popular en occidente e impopular en
casa sus políticas se resumían en dos
palabras del lado económico la
perestroika que significa
reestructuración y que promovía el
acceso a propiedad privada en ciertos
casos también a la apertura de un Libre
Mercado con occidente su otra política
era aglas que quiere decir libertad de
expresión y desencadenó una oleada de
debate público sin precedentes en la
historia de Rusia pues permitía por
ejemplo la publicación de libros hasta
el momento prohibidos también la
liberación de disidentes políticos y la
aceptación de credos Porque tan polémico
Daniela Paul porque Los partidarios de
la línea dura lo acusaron de destruir la
economía y de desechar siete décadas de
logros comunistas en los últimos días de
La Unión soviética El declive económico
se aceleró la hiperinflación privó a la
mayoría de las personas mayores de los
ahorros de toda su vida También muchas
fábricas cerraron se formaron filas
eternas para comprar comida y creció
entonces de esta manera el odio popular
hacia gorbachov y su esposa pues ellos
consideraban que la caída de sus niveles
de vida era un precio demasiado alto a
pagar por la democracia muchos de ellos
no todos cambiamos ahora de tema porque
Rusia volvió a suspender el flujo de gas
por el gasoducto North Street Pues el
gas promo mantendrá suspendido este
servicio hasta el sábado por el tubo que
lleva gas a Europa dice que es por
labores de mantenimiento rutinarias
justo cuando los países implantan planes
de ahorro energético y aceleran el
llenado de sus reservas que ya dicen
están al 80% de cara al próximo invierno
veamos la reacción de Alemania esta
noticia
realmente no entendemos la necesidad
técnica de este nuevo mantenimiento de
Rusia pero Alemania ahora está mejor
preparada hemos llenado más las
instalaciones de almacenamiento estamos
obteniendo gas de Noruega Países Bajos
Bélgica y pronto de Francia estamos
ahorrando gasolina y en este sentido
Supongo que seremos capaces de hacer
frente a esto por el momento en Europa
nos unimos a nuestra región Daniela
específicamente a mi país Venezuela
de un millonario fraude Dani Bueno pues
la denuncia la hizo la actual ministro
de petróleo tarjeta lizami contra Quien
fuera el jefe de esta cartera hace una
década estamos hablando de Rafael
Ramírez a la hija me dijo que Ramírez se
robó una millonaria suma a través de una
línea de crédito fraudulenta con la que
la estatal pedevesa hizo pagos a dos
fondos en el exterior sin haber recibido
nunca préstamo alguno
El primer pago que se hizo 14 días luego
de haber aceptado el supuesto
financiamiento que nunca existió en
bolívares lo convirtieron en una
operación fraudulenta a unos fondos en
el extranjero
verdad Y empezó a pedirles a pagar y
tenemos
todos los recibos que suman
la cantidad de
4.850 millones de dólares
en 28
recibo de transferencia Este es el
primero el 20 de marzo del 2012 por un
monto de 230 millones de dólares a este
fondo Violeta ahora de quién estamos
hablando Raúl de Rafael Ramírez él es un
chavista de larga Data que tras dejar el
cargo de ministro de petróleo en 2013
fue embajador del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro ante la ONU después fue
sustituido y de luego le dio la espalda
al mandatario hoy se defiende diciendo
que el gobierno lanzó otra olla podrida
en su contra y señala a tareca lizami de
ser buscado y sancionado por la justicia
internacional por graves delitos
incluido narcotráfico lo cual dice le
quita todas las intimidad a sus
acusaciones indicadores económicos
Daniela
abrió mixto después de una mala jornada
el martes en Europa las bolsas caen tras
conocerse que la inflación anotó un
nuevo récord en la zona Euro los precios
al consumidor en tuvieron 9,1%
interanual en agosto es decir frente
agosto del año pasado y esto agravó los
temores de recesión que ya venían
acechando los mercados el miércoles en
Asia las bolsas cerraron mixtas los
inversionistas Raúl del mundo también
están pendientes de los bancos centrales
de ambos lados del Atlántico Porque se
están preparando para seguir aumentando
Los costos de endeudamiento tanto para
las empresas como para los hogares el
próximo mes y esto como una manera de
combatir la inflación Dani como siempre
Gracias por toda la información
económica volamos directo y sin escalas
a París Ahí está nuestra periodista
Erika la bar